hi everybody thank you all for coming
out tonight I want to also thank Roger
Hertog that Hertog foundation for
supporting our program thanks also to
the mailman School of Public Health for
co-sponsoring this this lecture series
and for providing these beverages so I
also obviously want to thank David
Heyman for coming and joining us this
evening and unique among our speakers
this year and last year I should say is
he's the only one who asked me to go
light on the introduction and not to
heap praise on him at all I'll do that
I'll honor his his request
and I also just want to point out he
just comes to us after spending an hour
with our students and telling us what I
thought
without praising him too much we're
really fascinating stories about his
career one that began as a officer for
US Public Health Service in looking at
first outbreak of Legionnaires disease
in Philadelphia and continued on from
there with Ebola and spending 13 years
as medical epidemiologist in sub-saharan
Africa from the CDC he went on working
in the World Health Organization and
building up their program in
communicable diseases for a time he
headed the polio eradication program he
ended up at w-h-o is assistant
director-general from health security
and environment and finally he's now
chairman of the board of the UK's Health
Protection Agency so in all these ways I
think he's really the perfect person to
to address us tonight and talking about
the history and future of global Public
Health and pandemic threats so thank you
David Heyman
thanks very much first of all don't pay
any attention to the date I really did
put this together today but I used a
framework from before and forgot today
and Larry was in the front row can vouch
for that because I did miss his flat
right stick so anyway what Sidney would
like me to talk about is Sidney here now
Sidney sent a message off saying that
this is what you should know so this is
what I will try to convey
first of all diseases know no national
boundaries and second to historical
evolution of international national
collaboration so I'd start then with
epidemics and pandemics that really have
shaped history and this goes back to the
first millennium and there you can see
there are waves of disease plague and
and other diseases that went around the
world and are still known from their
history if you then look in the Middle
Ages you'll see that plague dominated
the map and plague came in waves across
Europe in the Middle Ages and then in
the 20th century the first major
pandemic in the 20th century was of
course the Spanish flu outbreak in the
early 20th century so you can see that
pandemics have been important throughout
history now there are oftentimes
difficulties in defining pandemics and
Larry Altman does Emily know hilarious
there is a journalist in New York Times
he actually was a medical doctor from
CDC and he was very interested in trying
to define a pandemic when people
announced that there was a pandemic the
swine flu but there are some common
things that everybody agrees on for a
pandemic and one of those is that it's a
new infectious disease to which there is
no antigenic recognition and or
population immunity which means that
it's new that nobody has antibody to it
and therefore everyone
is acceptable the second is that it
spread it must spread among populations
throughout the world in order to be a
pandemic it's not a pandemic if it only
occurs in the u.s. it's a what an
epidemic right the mortality rate is
usually not a factor because it's the
geographic spread that's important but
many pandemics in the past have had high
rates of mortality and they're often
emerging infections associated at the
human and interface so those are some
defining points for a pandemic can
anybody think of any more defining
points you're happy with these okay well
then let's go on because we'll talk
about some of the diseases that really
formed history and made history what are
the I want you to think of for diseases
that you believe throughout history have
shaped the way we think about infectious
diseases does anybody have any ideas
this is the first one yeah yeah I'm
smallpox okay anybody else have any idea
flu
throughout the history throughout the
history what do you say she'sa myiasis
yeah okay
cholera leprosy HIV in the present yeah
well there were four back in the
medieval times that shaped the way we
think about infectious diseases in the
world today and the first was played and
here you can see the plague doctor have
you seen this picture before many of you
had who knows what's in that mask in the
beak who knows hmm I can't hear well
that's close it's pepper and it was
pepper to keep the than the asthma all
these vapors from being able to pass it
was thought that the pepper would stop
that at least that's the story ivory
so anyway plague was certainly one of
the most important ones and in the 14th
century have wiped out a lot of people
in Venice including in this painting it
shows you Titan who was killed smallpox
you said it very important disease
throughout history was eradicated in
1980 how many people know how many
deaths there were from smallpox in 1967
the year that smallpox eradication began
and a year that a few in here can
remember how many how many deaths were
there DEA probably told you this when he
spoke with you a couple weeks ago
there were three million deaths in 1967
from smallpox can you imagine if you
were to look at a graph today putting
that three million deaths on a graph of
the high infectious disease killers
today it would be number two what would
be number one no no diarrheal disease
and children is number one number two
today is respiratory disease number
three today's TB number four is HIV to
number five is malaria
and then number six is measles but if
you put three million deaths from
smallpox in 1967 on the 2011 graph today
it would still be first or second movie
sentence it's just it was an incredible
disease but it's eradicated because of
what da Henderson told you a few weeks
ago a very successful program on
eradication
so the first was cholera very important
in shaping how we think about infectious
disease a second smallpox who was who
wants to save the third you said if
cholera cholera was very important and
still important an outbreak in Zimbabwe
that continues to go on today epidemics
and there was one in Haiti as you know
so a very important disease that shaped
history of infectious diseases and
nobody has yet said the fourth one and
it's one that concerns us mostly in the
Americas what is it
know think back in the history think
back to the Panama Canal yellow fever
yellow fever was the fourth major
infectious diseases that formed the way
we think about infectious diseases today
and these diseases were pandemic they
could cross borders they there was a
major epidemic of yellow fever in
Philadelphia and this is the in the
middle there is a notification about
that yellow fever and it still goes on
today sporadically in Latin America but
also in Africa in parts of Africa and if
it gets into an urban area it causes
major threat who knows how yellow fever
spreads nobody know yeah
mosquito yeah it's a disease that's in
monkeys that live high in the canopy in
the forest and they have their
mosquitoes and then there are mosquitoes
on the ground well when a monkey drops
dead with yellow fever and falls down
the land mosquitoes can feed on it and
then they feed on humans give them
yellow fever and then humans can pass it
to other humans if they're not sleeping
under bed beds so a very important
disease that shaped infectious diseases
and so there's always been a concern
about these diseases throughout the ages
in the 14th century remember the plague
in Venice that was the first time that
anybody tried to do anything about it
and what did they try to do quarantine
and who knows what a quarantine is yes
how many 40 days that's right 40 days
keep that ship at bay keep it up and the
harbor don't let it in did it work no
didn't work the rats died they didn't
they had no idea why they were doing
this they just wanted to keep people out
thinking that if they kept them 40 days
they would either all die if they had
plague or they would not have it then
they left them in or they took things
out so quarantine was attempted it
didn't work and as you know the
pandemics continued around the world but
then in the 19th century there was
really a lot of interest in Europe and
the Americas and there were ten
internationally international sanitary
conferences which were trying to
understand how to prevent the spread of
plague cholera yellow fever and smallpox
and those sanitary conferences ended up
with requirements that countries report
to each other when a disease one of
these four diseases cholera plague
yellow fever smallpox were occurring
then in 1920 there were the League of
Nations began to think more about how
they might expand this to the world in
in Geneva and finally in 1969 the World
Health Organization
develop the international health
regulations which are a convention an
international convention like the
tobacco convention and they have a
hundred 93 signatories the most of any
convention every country in the world
signed up to this convention does
anybody know what the ihr are as anybody
ever carried a yellow fever vaccination
card how many you've all participated in
the ihr because that's part of the ihr
yellow fever vaccination but in fact
what the international health
regulations were were to ensure the
maximum security against the
international spread of disease with a
minimum interference in world traffic
what does that mean not clear but there
was a book written about the regulations
which had in it predetermined measures
that a country could take if another
country reported one of those four
diseases and there were also guides to
ship sanitation and aviation sanitation
which required that certain measures
were taken at seaports and airports so
diff vectors of disease came in they
wouldn't be able to propagate within
that environment such as mosquitos and
rats and you know that the cable that
the ships have the de belem the cord and
various things to prevent these things
from happening so the international
health regulations were to ensure the
maximum security against the
international spread of disease with
minimum interference world traffic they
required really three things first was a
notification to w-h-o whenever a country
had cholera plague yellow fever or
smallpox before 1980 and reports were
only accepted from countries where the
event was occurring okay so if the US
had not break of yellow fever
they were required to report to w-h-o
there was Health Organization at the
borders we talked about that in seaports
and in airports frontier posts to
prevent vector proliferation and there
were health measures
to describe the maximum measures that a
country may require to protect against
cholera plague yellow fever and in the
past small pox and a good example is the
yellow fever vaccination card a country
when it reports - when it reported to WH
o under the international health
regulations had its report published in
the weekly epidemiological record which
comes out weekly WH o on the back page
in very small print and there you can
see a report I think it's cholera it's
very small it's hard to read on the back
page and the people who work at the
seaports and airports are expected to be
reading this we're expected to read this
and then we're expected to if it were
yellow fever require a vaccination card
if you're coming from that country or if
it were cholera in the past they used to
require a cholera vaccinations that's no
longer required because it wasn't
effective but these were the things that
could be done predetermined measures
when it was published and here's how it
worked a country in countries only could
report cholera plague yellow fever or
smallpox it was published in the weekly
epidemiological record there's the
publication and the national country the
country was able to stop it if they
wanted to they stopped the operation
they tried to stop it and other
countries could apply predetermined
measures a very passive system very very
passive system now do you think the
regulations were an effective means of
dealing with the international spread
infectious diseases did they work does
anybody know
anybody have any ideas yes good point
that's right especially in today's world
that's why in 1969 there was a little
bit different thinking there and there
is today so you can be carrying a
disease from one country to another in
the incubation period and nobody can
pick it up until you get sick anything
else what happened to you you and you
can't even assume that the country has
good public health it's a very difficult
issue so I think in general in 2003 and
it's important that we start we stopped
at 2003 because that was a turning point
in many ways but in 2003 it was clear
that the international health
regulations were not effective what
happened if a country refused to report
a disease anybody know what do you think
happened yeah there's no international
police of course there's no police force
that can recommend go after a country if
they don't report so countries didn't
report and they had reason not to report
and we'll talk about that first I just
want to say about between 1996 and 2003
there were many other diseases that were
occurring in addition to color played in
yellow fever that were important in the
world look at some of these there were
flu there were SARS there were all kinds
of diseases that were occurring that
that weren't even covered by the
international health regulations and in
addition when a country did report what
happened they lost money this shows you
the calling of cattle in the UK in the
1990s when they reported BSE because
they had to get rid of the disease and
they call
this could be pictures of chickens
burning for h5n1 it's a very expensive
thing to report and countries didn't
want to report because they lost money
when SARS occurred look at the economic
impact that occurred in Asia the graph
shows you the airport arrivals in Hong
Kong which went down when w-h-o said
don't travel there but then they came
back up but still that cost the economy
in Asia sixty billion dollars so these
things were very there was no incentive
to report if you reported what happened
you ended up with sanctions and and this
is this is the map UK 39 billion they
lost from mad cow when Peru reported
cholera first time in 100 years of
cholera entered the Americas they lost
770 million dollars because your country
in my country at least our country here
this country stopped all importation of
seafood and fresh water fish and
tourists stopped going in they lost
seven hundred seventy million dollars in
their first year of cholera cholera is
now endemic throughout Latin America
these were unwarranted sanctions yet
they occurred so why should a country
record a disease play in India they lost
1.7 billion dollars when they reported
the disease for no reason at all because
it wasn't spreading there was no reason
not to go to India there was no reason
to ban exports from imports from India
yet people did it so there was no
incentive to report and what happened
was the first case of the disease
occurred countries would wait to see
whether or not they would report some
would report some wouldn't but no matter
what happened there was a delayed
response and you lost an opportunity for
control and you uh you made is this a
risk of international or spread clearly
what was wanted was early reporting a
rapid response and potential cases
prevented in all countries not just in a
few so they throughout the world there
could be a level playing ground so now
what would you do next we've got the
international health regulations nine
69 countries sometimes reported most
times didn't if they did report they had
terrible trade sanctions so what would
you do next
and remember the ihr were an important
tool because 194 countries in the world
signed up to these unheard of for a
convention yeah
yeah that's one thing make it make it
important for countries to report what
else what would you do at this situation
you've got a set of regulations which
aren't working what would you do let me
tell you a little bit more about the
regulations and then you'll understand
maybe what to do next because the
international health regulations were
created by a very ingenious group these
regulations require made some
requirements but they also said that
they could be modified and that never
had to go again for reefs ignitor they
could be modified and countries could
dis adhere from sections that they
didn't like so if you were to modify it
all that had to happen was a country
just adhere so you could do whatever you
wanted to with this if you had a
consensus to do it and they could serve
as a valuable tool so it was decided
that there would be a revision of the
1969 International Health Regulations
and so how would you do that revision
anybody have any dish and the idea is
what would be your vision for that
revision here in the 21st century 20th
century well there was a vision that was
developed back in 1996 when we started
talking about revising them and that was
a world on the alert and able to detect
and respond to international infectious
disease threats within 24 hours using
the most up-to-date means of global
communication and collaboration and
Steve knows this well because he was
already doing this do you in fact in the
back in the 90s with with chromium which
had been set up to do just this alert
and detect disease and then to respond
to those diseases but the second this
this at least was able to set up a
global mechanism to do it but the second
thing was that understanding that there
couldn't be a police force there had to
be some way in which the norms
surrounding reported of infectious
diseases couldn't be changed making it
expected and respected to report not
just being reporting but making it
expect
make sure that countries would hold
other countries accountable for
reporting because those were the two
keys to the to the revision as it was
seen in other words set in operation a
way of working that could then be
incorporated into the ihr well one of
the first things after promet was set up
it was developed was the global Public
Health Information Network in Canada and
I know there are some Canadians here as
well the Canadian government in support
of w-h-o developed a web crawling
mechanism which now crawls the web in
seven languages looking for outbreaks of
infectious diseases using keywords those
that information was then translated
overnight in or during the day rather in
Canada and sent overnight to Geneva for
action within the w-h-o system and this
is how it worked in February of 1999
the Canadian global Public Health
Information Network reported a highly
fatal respiratory disease in Afghanistan
now the fear was that this was some kind
of a deliberate use of anthrax or some
type of the disease because it was in a
very shady part of the world in
Afghanistan was somebody working to try
to use weapons were they developing
weapons what happened so there was great
concern on this and whu-oh sent a local
team for a preliminary investigation
their collaborative team then went in
and investigation was completed and
diagnosis was confirmed but let's move
back to the 16th of February where do
you think gphin picked up that report of
the highly fatal respiratory disease it
was it yeah no but it was close it was
in it was in Tajikistan just next door
it had been written in a local language
newspaper on the border with Afghanistan
that there was an hour
was translated into English and made it
to an English language website in
Dushanbe and gphin picked it up there
that information was acted on it turned
out that this was just a simple seasonal
influenza epidemic in a part of the
world that hadn't had influenza season
11 and influence over 30 years so that
people weren't protected they died it
was highly fatal but it turned out to
the influenza to the power of this
system not only detecting been able to
respond within a fairly short period of
time so all of a sudden WH o through G
fen and through promet and others found
that they really had many many more
reports from sources away from countries
than they did from countries the red
shows your country reporting through the
w-h-o system and the green shows you
recording that was picked up
electronically around the world now
remember what the international health
regulations said about reporting
diseases who reported diseases to wh
other countries only yeah and here was a
new way of working and it was a very
risky way well the legal department and
w-h-o didn't like this because we were
breaking the law international law we
were taking reports from other places
acting upon them and not only from
countries what would you do in that
situation well you get a good evidence
base first as to why you might want to
break the law but then you should try to
recruit the director-general and others
and continue which we did and there was
a good director general who said yes we
continue so that was the way that
reporting became a global thing breaking
the rules but it still wasn't legalized
and and then this whole system developed
where w-h-o was taking information from
formal sites and from informal sites
around the world including from Edun he
was active with it that
gphin from NGOs like the Red Cross and
Red Crescent Societies or medicines some
frontier whatever groups all around
collecting information acting on it and
when the information came in to WH o if
it was confirmed then WH I went out to a
group of partners the people that were
working in these networks and asked if
anyone could help partner with WH o to
work on the outbreak response should the
country request new way of working a new
way of working that could hopefully be
incorporated into international health
regulations which was a way that WH o
began to work and here were some of the
outbreaks in 1999 the WH o and its
partners recruited through electronic
means we're able to deal with infections
around the world now what happened in
March 2003 was very important for the
International Health Regulations because
in March 2003 as you remember a doctor
from the Guangdong Province in China who
had been treating people with an unknown
pneumonia went into Hong Kong and stayed
overnight in a hotel one night he was
going to a wedding the next day but he
was quite sick it's thought that he
vomited in the hallway but somehow in
that hotel he was able to infect people
with the same disease yet unknown that
spread off that spread around the world
to Canada Ireland the u.s. Singapore
Vietnam and into parts of Hong Kong so
one person coming out of China's spread
this disease around the world 2003 if
any of you remember it caused quite a
bit of panic in the world this is the
this is one area of transmission on a
plane
China air lay weighs 112 from Hong Kong
to Beijing either in the waiting room or
on the plane the person circled infected
flight attendants and passengers on that
playing this for just one example spread
around the world and then w-h-o called
into operation its partners who were
working in this global operation alert
and response network to help with this
outbreak and this shows you where the
experts came from 26 institutions in 17
countries permitted whu-oh to put field
teams in five countries where the
outbreaks were occurring and permitted
information in real time that could then
be converted into recommendations on
what to do about travel and so w-h-o
really overstepped its grounds this was
a disease not contained at all in the
International Health Regulations which
had been received through electronic
reporting I didn't give you the way that
it was detected that it was detected by
promed and Japan and a whole group of
people that provided this information in
WH o and WH o used the evidence to act
and to make recommendations on travel
the outbreak did stop WH o we'd love to
claim the credit and possibly did do a
lot in in stopping this because there
was a very vulgar Ector general who
actually not only made some very
important decisions but if you remember
that vision we talked about about
changing the norm for reporting make it
expected and respected to report she
accused China in public finger-pointing
China saying you're not reporting this
disease and this is spreading around the
world it's all it took to China the next
day the Vice Premier was on a plane up
to Geneva to talk with the
director-general and China controlled
the disease so that was the beginning of
a new way of working partnership around
the world electronic surveillance and a
responsibility to report expected and
respected and so fortuitously the
outbreak was occurring from March to
June and May is when the World Health
Assembly
meets in Geneva so this gave the
opportunity to w-h-o to really conquer
ties the way that it had been working
unofficially and against legals wishes
by a resolution that everybody signed
because everybody was afraid and it
permitted w-h-o to report infectious
diseases from other sources than member
states all infectious diseases with
potential for international spread
should be reported and revised
international health regulations were to
serve as a formal framework for
proactive international surveillance and
response through national focal points
so a whole new way of working in a
resolution now who knows what a
resolution is does this do anything does
this require anything for countries no
it doesn't its political will but it
gave w-h-o a mandate to move ahead with
a revision of the international health
regulations and so in 2005 that revision
was accomplished
it went from reporting of three diseases
what worthy cholera playing yellow fever
smallpox with smallpox wasn't not on in
nineteen when the revision occurred it
went to all public health threats not
only infectious diseases but others it
went from a passive system remember how
passive it was a country reported it
then got published and then if you read
it you could respond to it when
proactive using real-time surveillance
and real-time evidence as had been done
in SARS when it was determined where
people should not travel using real-time
evidence and it went from trying to
control it the borders to detection and
containment at the source three major
changes in the philosophy of the ihr all
public health threats proactive and
detection and containment at the source
rather than waiting till it spreads
international those regulations require
mandatory reporting of possible public
health
of international importance and this
shows you a decision tree developed up
in Sweden the karlon scheme for wh o
which shows a series of questions in the
decision tree that helps countries and
whi working together decide whether what
they have is a possible public health
emergency of international importance of
faith Phe I see it's the second
requirement in the revised regulations
is strengthen national core capacity for
surveillance and control this means that
countries are required in the seven
years after the regulations became came
into force which was in 2007 they're
required to have a minimum Public Health
Laboratory and minimum surveillance
system within their countries and
they're being monitored by the World
Health Assembly the governing body of
w-h-o to be sure that they do that they
required a national focal point to
ensure that there was 24-hour
communication remember the vision 24
hours communication on the alert within
each country and there's a committee
that's been set up to oversee these
regulations this is how you decide if
you have what's called a faith a public
health emergency of international
concern there are four diseases that
always must be required why do you
suppose those diseases need to be
required reported polio smallpox because
they're erratically eradicating or
eradicated diseases influenza because
you can see what happens when a new
betters and SARS which was thought
possibly too can be a reoccurring
disease which it turned out was a
one-time event so those were the four
diseases that went in by name then there
are diseases that should always lead to
utilization of an algorithm of this
algorithm on the right and those are
cholera pneumonic plague yellow fever
viral hemorrhagic fever others looking
to see their public health impact
unusual or unexpected risk of
international spread risk of travel and
trade and then if there's insufficient
information there needs to be a
reassessment as more information comes
this tool is used by w-h-o in countries
to decide whether they have a public
health emergency of international
concern which must then be reported so
all of a sudden there's been a new way
of working developed which is now
proactive instead of passive public
health risks can be reported by
countries and countries are expected to
report whether it's an outbreak or a
chemical spill or whatever that might
cross borders but also public health
risk reporting comes in from WH OHS
surveillance around the world and others
that feed into that network then there's
a decision tree analysis with the
country and you saw the decision tree
fear to determine whether it's urgent
international Public Health importance
and if it is then a country is required
to work with w-h-o to make to develop
the measures that will prevent that
disease from spreading outside that
country and they're required to stop
that outbreak from occurring and if it's
not public health emergency of
international importance then countries
can do what they wish with that disease
but they're being monitored to
strengthen their public health system so
do you think that these revised
regulations meet the vision for their
revision that was put up way way back
was a world on the alert able to detect
and respond to infectious diseases and
reporting expected and respected do you
think that they're there meeting some of
those goals do you think their
weaknesses in them
anybody have any idea it's late in the
day well there are only seven languages
I have any friends since the
surveillance that's being done I mean
yeah yeah so there were certain gaps in
what's going on yeah there's there lots
of gaps in them but they are regulations
they're international law but
international law cannot be enforced
unfortunately so do you think the ihr
will be used or are being used well
let's look at an example back in - this
is the wrong slide I'm sorry this should
be h5n1 and it should be Phase three
because h5n1 was a Phase three alert
back in 2007 it was a Phase three
this is the wrong slide so it was a
human infection with a new virus but
there was only infrequent spread
remember this is a disease that comes
from chickens into humans and it was
spreading occasionally in other humans
in Vietnam one time and in others bird
flu very serious issue in countries were
providing the virus to w-h-o because WHL
needs those viruses in order to
determine what's going on in the world
and also to develop a strain for vaccine
so it was required now back in 2007 when
it was declared a Phase three
the Minister of Health of Indonesia said
that Indonesia which had the most cases
of bird flu at that time was going to
stop sharing viruses internationally how
many remember that and she said that
because and she was right she's right
she said why should we be sharing
viruses and let a vaccine be developed
and we won't have any benefit from them
and she had experience because in 2007
her president told her I want you to get
two million doses of h5n1 vaccine and I
want it stored in Indonesia in case
there's an outbreak I want our health
workers and of course his family and
others to be vaccinated so she was sent
on a mission to get a vaccine that was
made with the strain from Indonesia she
went to a pharmaceutical company that I
won't name who had the virus who had
developed a vaccine and they said fine
they said you can have the vaccine
here's the cost same causes in the US
and everywhere else and besides not only
that you're number 32 on the waiting
list because there are 32 countries
ahead of you that have asked for vaccine
and paid for it
so she couldn't fulfill the national
need that her president perceived and it
made her very concerned and she
rightfully concerned she wanted to know
if she wanted people know that her virus
was used for vaccine they should also
get some of the vaccine so in March of
2007 they were able to articulate
through a meeting in Jakarta what
benefits they wanted they wanted
strengthened laboratory capacities in
their own countries in developing
countries to qualify for w-h-o
collaborating Center designation now a
w-h-o collaborating Center is a
laboratory paid for by a country that
does work for w-h-o in the u.s. there
are about 22
w-h-o collaborating centers at CDC that
deal with things ranging from flu to
Ebola and there are collaborating
centers in most industrialized countries
in the world because they have the
skills to do that she wanted some
collaborating centers and developing
countries but developing countries never
had stood up at that point said we'll
put the money into those labs because
whu-oh hasn't put money in it's that but
she wanted w-h-o to put money into
developing country labs so they could
reach the same standard as
industrialized country labs the
questionable requests but that was what
she made
second was she wanted more transparent
buyers handling within w-h-o because
when these viruses came to WH o nobody
knew where they went they just came in
stayed there but they went into industry
they went into developing of tests and a
whole series of things she want
sustained access to pandemic vaccines
and she wants to link virus sharing and
vaccine production to sustainability of
those benefits
now she was right in many ways but she
put the world with risk because there
was a gap in knowledge about what was
going on in Indonesia so do the revised
international health regulations can can
they play a role in this and if not tell
what more could be done think back to
the revised regulations remember one of
the reported diseases required reporting
was influenza of a new character so it
was required to be reported but do you
think they could play a role in this or
did they play a role in this well let's
move on article 2 says that the
regulations require countries to prevent
protect against control and provide a
public health response to international
spread of disease commensurate with
public health risks this is a
requirement w-h-o must be sure that
that's met the only way that you can
prevent protect against control and
provide a public health response to the
International spread of disease is to
know where that disease is occurring to
know where h5n1 was occurring you needed
to have laboratory tests that could
detect h5n1 and the only way you could
develop those tests was if you had
viruses that you could test them against
so number one you needed to add those
viruses coming into w-h-o
in addition w the the there was a
requirement to protect in the only way
you can protect is with vaccine the only
way you could get a vaccine was to
develop a strain which could be used to
develop that gene now think about the
h5n1 virus what does it do to chickens
kills how is influenza vaccine made it's
made in eggs
groaning fertilized eggs and embryos if
you have a virus that kills chickens you
can't grow it in eggs it has to be
genetically modified in a way that it
won't kill those eggs so you can develop
a vaccine the only way you can do that
is if you have live virus and use it for
those vaccines so there was every reason
that Indonesia had to share that vaccine
it said it right here and x2 helped to
determine if an event constitutes an
emergency requires joint risk assessment
a whole series of reasons why that virus
was needed and clearly Indonesia was in
abeyance of the international health
regulations that had just been revised
through a tremendous amount of work did
w-h-o countries decide to use these
regulations to enforce reporting or to
say let's get on with the job no
countries decided instead through a
resolution less strong to develop an
intergovernmental process which has
involved meetings since 2007 and you can
see that the Intergovernmental meetings
have now ended in 2011 and they finally
come to a way of maybe sustaining a
little bit of this but still haven't met
the requirement for pandemic vaccine so
a whole series of things that cost over
five million dollars instead of using
the international health regulation so
countries may not use it and I guess I
asked you why you thought they chose not
to use it
they worked hard to revise them why
didn't they use them anybody have any
ideas well think of the US this is the
u.s. one people to put sanctions on them
if they don't report a disease and do
they report all diseases who knows they
don't sometimes so you know countries
when it came to implementing these are
enforcing these regulations all of a
sudden put themselves in the seat of
Indonesia and said well if we do this to
Indonesia maybe they'll do it back to us
and so in the end they made it a less
strong response and they didn't use the
international health regulations are
there any questions at this point I
think we're probably running out of time
are we - and when do we 20 we and 7:00
7:30 okay so are there any any
observations at this point how could you
make sure they're used the next time is
there any way it's really tough
it's really tough we've got a beautiful
international tool just like we have a
beautiful tobacco convention and now the
u.s. is going to decide whether or not
they're going to sign up to that
convention but it's really tough to make
things happen internationally very tough
but anyway um the regulations are there
and they're there just in time because
of the emerging infections agenda and
you all know this did somebody talk to
you about emerging infections well these
are the important ones for international
health regulations because they zoom
across borders very easily and they
usually occur at the human-animal
interface and this shows you some of the
selected ones since 1976 and you can see
that there are many different ones
occurring Jones at all in nature in 2008
showed that these emerging infections
were all classes of organism that we
know their bacterial their viral their
parasitic and their fungal all these
emerging infections can be of any and
they occur everywhere in the world and
there are some hotspots but they do
occur everywhere in the world now the
reason that these diseases are so
difficult to deal with is because they
can take three different pathways
anybody know those pathways well the
first pathway is they can cross the
barrier between an animal and a human
they infect a human and they go no
further
what's a good example of that does
anybody know any examples of that sorry
h5n1 at present yeah mm-hmm anything
else
monkey pox that's right usually doesn't
spread oh no I'm sorry monkey pox does
spread but you'll see this is no further
transmission at all and you gave a good
example Salmonella from eggs is another
example a good example in Europe because
I developed this for a European audience
was Legionnaires disease which was in
the air conditioning that the Catalan
trade fair in Belgium in 1999 and
infected people who went back to various
European countries but a disease which
comes probably from a pigeon or the an
animal into the water conditioned water
of the air-conditioning system and
somehow through a leak gets out and
infects a whole group of people who are
attending an event such as this one the
Legionnaires disease so a disease that
emerges and has no further human to
human transmission then there are others
that emerged they continued transmission
for a while and then they cease or
become sporadic and this is the monkey
Fox example but there are other examples
of that as well who else can give other
examples
monkey pox can can transmit for maybe
two or three generations and then it's
too weak to continue transmission that
dies out
SARS SARS was a disease that didn't have
enough time to show whether it would do
that or not it continued to spread for a
while but whether or not it would have
slowed down nobody knows because it
stopped before then West Nile
let's see West Nile comes yeah I guess
it could be spread from human to human
by mosquitoes but it's usually from an
animal yeah yeah
SIV HIV spreads from human to human and
it hasn't stopped yet we don't know in
the history of things but it's it's
still going I'll give you the example
that we used in in Europe in an in a
meeting human influenza
aah 7 & 7 & aah 3 were in poultry in the
Netherlands they infected humans and
they transmitted a bit that than they
stopped and this is common to these
influenza viruses and poultry but then
there's one that emerges and it
continues transmission and then it
becomes endemic and you've already said
the classic example of that is HIV and
this shows you HIV it probably came most
likely came from non-human primate and
humans in the late 19th or early 20th
century and then gradually became
endemic and then became a pandemic when
it started amplifying in cities where
there was risky behavior and airplanes
that took it around the world and HIV is
not an endemic diseases infecting
populations all over the world this
again is a European example so you've
got three different different patterns
of emergence no further transmission
continue to transmit cease and sporadic
or continues transmission and continues
and becomes endemic SARS was a disease
that there was concern that it might do
just what HIV did spread around the
world then become endemic either in
humans or in animals who could then
spread it periodically to humans but
fortunately it didn't get into Africa
where surveillance was weak
it was found in most places and didn't
but the other thing about these emerging
infections is they can increase variants
or decrease variants so an h5n1 that is
very very land now could become less
virulent as it passes through humans and
it replicates and mutates or to become
even more very nobody knows what will
happen so these are the very tricky
diseases and these are the essence of
those four diseases in history cholera
plague yellow fever and smallpox in the
21st century these are the disease's
where there's focus today these are the
disease
people are concerned about under the
international health regulations now I'm
just going to finish because we're
facing some new events which are going
to make life even more complicated
and those include such things as climate
change and health and extreme weather
events which are now giving us a glimpse
no matter what the bush government said
they're giving us a glimpse of what's
going to happen in the future and this
shows you what they occur as increasing
storms flooding droughts at the same
time food shortages increase in
temperature heat waves a whole series of
things and they're really personified
very well in the Rift Valley fever in
Sudan in 1998 who knows what Rift Valley
fever is Steve that's right Rift Valley
fever is a viral disease carried by
cattle and non-and and ruminants
ruminant animals cattle sheep goats and
it spreads to humans by two means either
a mosquito
the first vent the cattle and then the
human or by the blood during the
slaughter of an animal so it's a virus
that infects humans it's a very serious
infection about 30 to 35 percent can die
it's a very serious viral disease and
this young young man in Sudan became
infected and he did die but this
outbreak occurred at the time when there
was flooding in East Africa due to an El
Nino event and what does flooding do why
did this outbreak occur at this time
that's one thing
breeding ground for mosquitoes what else
okay drowns cattle yeah it could drown
cattle but what happens is the cattle
and the humans move closer together on
dry land so you got the perfect storm if
you would for an operator I like to call
this a Swiss cheese event you know what
is miss cheese event is if you want to
pass a pencil through five pieces of
Swiss cheese what you have to do you
line up five holes and so this was the
beginning of a Swiss cheese event and
it's a very complicated event first of
all there was flooding for humans and
animals closer together
animals were infected with Rift Valley
fever and there was an increase in
mosquitoes that could transmit the virus
from animals to humans you with me the
next whole routine vaccination of Rift
Valley fever in East Africa this is a
requirement if you want to export
animals from East Africa they have to be
vaccinated against Rift Valley fever and
this shows you the vaccination that was
occurring in East Africa but there was
insufficient veterinary vaccine produced
in the 1990s in Kenya and Calvin were no
longer being vaccinated as they should
be there was still vaccine that the
majority of cattle weren't vaccinated so
here were these cattle forced into close
proximity with humans and increase in
mosquitoes so there was an outbreak of
Rift Valley fever in Sudan but animal
husbandry is one of the major sources of
revenue for Sudan and where does that
revenue come from where does it trade
trades across the Red Sea into the
Arabian from Yemen Saudi Arabian Yemen
and all over the Saudi Arabian Peninsula
so there was a lot of trade going on
with livestock and these are the cattle
and there were also goats and this is
especially true what time of year huh
that's right it's very important when
the religious sacrifices are good now
this is the port Sayid port and you see
two types of boats here and they're
shown for a reason because the bigger
ships take legal trade across the red
see but the smaller votes take illegal
trade across the race
legal trade requires that animals are
vaccinated the illegal trade does that
even legal trade you can buy a
vaccination certificate very easily so
even legal trade is dangerous
but this is the this is the increase in
those Swiss cheese holes now vaccinate
unvaccinated cattle and trade across
Yemen in the Red Sea and there was not
break a Rift Valley fever in animals and
humans in 2000 in Saudi Arabia and Yemen
same genetic strain has occurred in East
African Rift Valley fever outbreaks two
years earlier so a complicated series of
events but these are the events for
which the international health
regulations were developed but the most
important thing in them is to help
countries strengthen their own public
health so that these diseases don't
spread internationally so that's what I
wanted to say about the ihr and I'm
happy to answer any questions any of you
might have
okay if you have questions I've asked
you to speak into the microphone since
we're we're webcasting this typically
here at home as people make their way
let me just ask a question in my own so
when you described what happened with
with Indonesia and you know viral
sovereignty it occurred to me that that
you know maybe it's occurred to many
other people too but that you could take
that as at least potentially a solution
or the beginning one where you could
incentivize countries to report disease
by promising them that they would be the
first in line right and maybe they'd
have other benefits too and in upgrading
laboratories and and so on says is is
that potentially something that could be
done to help you know you know bring
about greater compliance with
international health regulations I think
it's very important it certainly can if
you know I'll go back to the biological
weapons convention because Steve was a
big help in helping us understand that
there was a clause in the biological
weapons convention before it collapsed
in the verification procedure that said
that countries from industrialized
countries signatories would provide
resources to signatories from developing
countries for better public health so
incentives were attempted in that
unfortunately the negotiations collapsed
and it never met committed they come
back one day but it collapsed but yes
incentives are important sometimes to
use in the issue of virus sharing what
what the Minister of Health was
attempting to do was to imitate a very
important convention or treaty that's
been signed in the seed industry and the
FAO
and this has signatories from the US it
has many many
does anybody know about that it's a very
interesting it's a very interesting
mechanism that the Indonesians wanted to
have used and it has to do with the
biodiversity what am I the Convention on
biodiversity sitting up in Montreal I
think it is Canada under that seeds were
treated as sovereign and sovereign goods
so if a seed came from your country
belong to you even if it blew in from
some other country belong to you and you
had rights over that seed so the FAO
with the consent of the farmers seed
industry because they saw a benefit to
this developed a convention which said
that FAO would take all sequence
information from all seeds and store it
in a seed bank and also seeds themselves
and if a country or an industry wanted
those seeds they could take those seeds
and they could develop new seeds from
them but they would have to pay 10% of
their profits from those new seeds into
a sustainability fund if they patented
if they didn't patent they had to pay
nothing into that fund were welcome to
pay if they wanted to
well that sustainability fund was set up
and it's quite successful it's it's an
automated process and you know
information goes in and out in and out
in and out and there's a fund that's
been set up in the FAO it's not yet
fully operational because countries
haven't all signed on it but it was the
model that the Indonesians were trying
to use for virus sure there was only one
difficulty and that was that as of that
time the CBD the CBD had not yet looked
at viruses looked at bacteria to see
whether or not they were also sovereign
property but there were the Nagoya
rounds which occurred last year which
did say that virus can be southern
property so now there is a way that if
groups begin to work on this they
something in the CBD that says that
viruses belong to a country and if that
country gives them they must have some
benefit from them so that's how things
work internationally changes are
occurring this was the vision of the
Minister of Health of Indonesia but she
dropped it after a couple sessions and
she just was after other things and just
more importantly to keep this visible
globally so yeah
there can be incentives and I think
sustainability funds things like that
are very important okay thanks I just
wanted to slightly follow up on that
thanks a lot for a very clarifying talk
actually about a very complicated
subject which is that were there in fact
changes in the 2005 regulations which
made the mechanism for giving assistance
to countries with outbreaks more
streamlined I guess I mean it's
something you sort of didn't quite say
yeah you can't force a country to take
support and to stop an outbreak even
under the International Health
Regulations but it's just this new norm
and standard that's being said and
that's what's most important expected
and respected you know and if a country
doesn't allow support from w-h-o and
partners to go in and stop it they will
be ostracized internationally
unfortunately many director-general
won't point a finger like Berlin did who
was the director gentleman in back in
1997 or 2003 rather but I always like to
tell a story about Brooklyn brendlin was
a real dynamo she was a real public
health person because she was a PDA
pediatrician with an mph from Harvard
yet she was a prime minister previously
in new head
politics she when she accused China
publicly of not having a reported she
had already already knew that she wasn't
running for a second term
she already cited so you know there are
politics involved I myself believe the
Brundtland would have done it no matter
what she was very confident she would
have done it and she would have won
again but some directors general may not
find it useful to accuse a country in
their first term yeah so they can't make
it expected but that's the stick element
but what about the carrot element was
that also changed in other words did the
regulations also say countries will get
yeah be that's that one general response
they will get a global response yeah
they also hopefully the bilateral donors
like USAID and others will buy into
strengthening the infrastructure in
public health so the countries can do a
better job than so yeah so there is an
incentive and if countries take the
international health regulations and go
to different the UK development agency
and say here's our plan for resource for
strengthening our resources in public
health they'll get money if they go to
USAID it's variable it depends on your
country office so we have to play a role
we have to get our development agencies
to understand that they're important in
this for incentivize thank you very much
if it's okay I have two questions
actually so first of all returning to in
earlier slides in your talk you
mentioned defining first of all defining
a pandemic and then what you saw is the
four most important pandemics and I was
just wondering why and I'll mention just
a detail or two but why you didn't
include the the 1918 influenza pandemic
on that list because in your definition
you said that something about novel
antigenic recognition and like novel
that there is no population immunity
before him and I said before that you
listed to my knowledge they're not
cyclic diseases like they don't recur
every season and I think that the 1918
pandemic was a really good example of
how like antigenic drift and things like
that can cause a pen
make out of normal epidemic recurring
diseases sigh I feel like that would be
extremely important let me try to answer
that what what I was trying to show you
was I was trying to put it in the
context of historical before nineteen
before the 20th century and and flu
probably occurred in pandemics that it
was never really described as was
cholera plague yellow fever those were
really clearly described in the
literature but flu was never really
clearly described it so it didn't play a
major role in the ihr or in the
conventions in the 19th century okay yes
thank you it was very important yes
right and the other one is so you
discussed the ihr revisions during 2005
and you said that regarding like
specific diseases and response plans and
things like that specific things were
highlighted like SARS for example and
new incidences of the flu and I was just
wondering why you thought that this
wasn't made more fluid in other words it
wasn't left open completely to say any
novel outbreak like SARS for example was
a novel outbreak so they'll have
precedence over any novel outbreak to
take what measures they see fit SARS
would have fit into that decision tree
was made the decision tree is very
important and SARS would have fit the
criteria in that decision tree in fact I
teach at the London School of Hygiene
and Tropical Medicine and there's a
student there doing his master's who's
doing looking at outbreaks that have
occurred in the past 10 years and trying
to see how many of those would have fit
into the these are outbreaks which were
recorded as crossing borders how many
would have fit into that decision tree
so there you know there it does include
other diseases and stars would have
probably fit into that so I have a
question regarding the the health
ministers request for funds for creating
a local collaborative center I believe
to term those and and in general
creating more domestic and regional
capabilities for for developing vaccines
on a local level it seems to me that by
starting the monitor and moving away
from self reporting the initiative has
kind of been taken away from the
individual countries and it's it's more
of an active approach as you mentioned
so really countries can't decide anymore
whether or not to to report so it seems
to me it would make sense to provide
these capabilities and I don't know
maybe we can share some some light into
whether or not that's feasible you know
electronic reporting in itself is
incentivizing because countries don't
want somebody else to report their
diseases today they'd rather report it
first and so what's happened is I showed
you a graph of 2003 if you look today
the majority of in fact of disease is
being reported by countries it's changed
again it's come back to countries but
now they're reporting more completely
and less is being detected by electronic
means it's being detected but it's
already been reported so there has been
it changes that does that answer your
question I was wondering whether or not
funds are going to be made available or
whether that the process started of
funds being made available for countries
such as Indonesia to create the messy
capabilities of of creating vaccines and
kind of tackling the problem when it
occurs there actually were the u.s. and
Japan provided funding to w-h-o to help
developing countries transfer technology
for influenza vaccine for pandemic
vaccine and that program went under way
it was very difficult program because
industry dug its heels in in most
instances and didn't want to transfer
the technology because their solution
was to develop their own companies their
own factories in those countries that
and have nationally do it so it wasn't
entirely effective but there was a
transfer of technology on a couple
instances into Indonesia and Thailand
one was from Russia technology transfer
into
Thailand and Indonesia from Japan so
there were some successful and the World
Bank bought into that as well so the
countries could develop industries to
produce vaccines is that and then did
those countries then just choose to
violate patents like Brazil would in
some cases or did they interesting flu
vaccine is not that there's nothing
patented in flu vaccine today it's only
when you have new genetic material it's
so so there were no patents involved it
was just the fact that what was patented
were procedures and some of the kind of
companies wouldn't transfer those
procedures thank you
this was a fascinating a little bit out
of my domain I have something of an
ignorant question you mentioned the seed
bank and the like as I recall and I hard
for me to dated but pharmaceutical
companies and building their real
laboratories not there in silico
libraries rather not there in silico
libraries of possible agents have been
going all over islands and the like and
cutting various kinds of deals with the
various of the countries and I don't
know some of them I think may be
licensing some of them patents but
surely that can be a model used it may
be fairly sophisticated now of course we
know that the chances of what's in a
plastic bucket from some Island will
probably not turn out to be a sellable
drug but anyway there's there's a lot of
expertise there that that might be it
seems to me of used to the
not-for-profit community NIH actually
has a program where they screen young
products that come from yeah especially
for cancer yeah and you know I think
that's that's reasonable that's how we
got a new ant
our tenets are coming from a Chinese
cucumber and then now it's been there's
an attempt to synthesize it chemically
we can't produce it but those things are
very important yeah and you know
pharmaceutical companies are really a
part of the solution they're not a
problem in this except that they they do
tend not to pay attention to developing
country needs a mister
I was wondering on if we talked about
proactive measures and I understand
there was a trouble of funding and
getting other countries to get involved
in accept a lot of the World Health
Organization's passes however I was
wondering if there's anything that
they're doing actively as far as
vaccinations go pre-emptive in possible
hazardous areas things like that that
the world has taken over yellow fever is
a good example yellow fever used to be
just a vaccine which was used to protect
travelers and people like that now it's
been integrated into routine
immunization programs throughout the
belt in Africa and in Latin America
where yellow fever occurs same as
happening with meningitis there are
places where meningitis occurs more
frequently in Africa in the Saharan area
now there are vaccines being integrated
into programs is it going funny's
directly through the countries or
through the World Health Organization
well the Health Organization makes the
recommendation the vaccines are then
provided initially by what's called Gavi
the Global Alliance on vaccines and then
countries are expected to pay for them
eventually Iceland thank you thanks very
much I'm just wondering how long does
the ihr remain relevant in terms of
endemic diseases you look at the case of
HIV clearly HIV isn't on the list but
h5n1 is h5n1 s been around for 14 years
and clearly some would argue that is
endemic in a lot of the countries does
the hir remain relevant to those
situations and and how do you how do you
determine if it is a disease become
endemic or not early yeah it has to be a
disease which is is new
newly spreading HIV doesn't qualify
because if HIV had been detected much
much earlier back in the early 19th 20th
century then it maybe something could
have been done but by the time it was
detected it was already spread
throughout the world
so HIV wouldn't have fit in that but you
know I think that the HIV experience is
what made countries more interested in
trying to develop partnerships to stop
the spread of diseases so I think it
served a very important very important
function but that didn't answer what you
want
yeah and that's right and and in the
meantime swine flu came in and the ihr
were used in swine flu because the
recommend the pandemic was declared
through the International Health
Regulations so the regulations are there
but they weren't used for h5n1 remember
the Indonesian Minister didn't use it
but should there be sustained human even
transmission the ihr will play a role
again and things will change but the ihr
are weakened one in one thing and that
is that they don't provide for sharing
of vaccines or goods they only provide
for sharing of information and strains
so it is a weakness you know countries
need they're required there they're set
up to help stop the spread international
spread of vaccine of disease yet they
don't provide the tools that countries
need to do it countries expected to
provide them themselves that's just the
nature of today's world we have to all
strive to increase sustained access of
all goods to all countries
I'm David if I could I have another
question for you um one of the things
you said in your talk reminded me of
something da Henderson said a couple
weeks ago about how it is that if you're
doing this kind of work they're going to
be times when you need to break the
rules and
what you should do then is go ahead and
do it but but be ready to apologize
afterward and you added to that it's
sort of like the rule about breaking
rules you added to that by saying that
you should also have some evidence to
show why it was necessary of course I
break the rules and DA wouldn't agree
with it okay well in both cases it seems
to me you know you're presenting in a
very positive way how it is that you
need to be on you know you need to be
flexible and you need to be to show
initiative and so on and that's all
commendable but can you think of some
examples where you know that readiness
to break the rules had had less salutary
you know consequences where some some
negative you know lessons you know about
how it is I think clearly the fact that
China broke the rules and didn't report
SARS was a good example of how it can
happen they broke the rules sorry became
pandemics yeah you know there are
consequences both positive and negative
but that's why I say you need the
evidence right before you break a rule
well especially in working for an
organization like w-h-o in many cases
these rules reflect the principle of
state sovereignty right and so the w-h-o
you know is nothing if it's not
accountable to the member states so you
know if you think of it that way you
know there are many who would say more
generally that in the the whole realm of
international development assistance to
think of it that way that all too often
you know international organizations and
NGOs are ready to override you know kind
of local government government
structures you know and so on and so
that is kind of a more general problem
so we had really positive examples of
you know leaders like da Henderson and
and
you know who ready to be flexible to put
it that way but nonetheless it may be
part of the larger problem you know it's
a big problem it's an ethical problem I
mean is it ethical to be giving aids
drugs when we don't know that that can
be sustained in the long term to be
doing that the ethics of post-conflict
situations in healthcare and just in
general of outbreaks are really
interesting because you know the CDC
where I come from goes in and does not
break investigation every time there's
an outbreak at the invitation of the
country but then they take the data out
and it's worked on back in the US is
that ethical is that ethical if you find
that this disease was caused by
something which could be prevented is it
ethical to have done the investigation
and that provided the vaccine to prevent
a whole series of ethical issues it's
very important metrics and I'm not I'm
not clear on all of them but I'm working
right now at Chatham House which is a
political think tank in London with a
guy named lily white who used to be the
Surgeon General of the UK military like
our Surgeon General here and he's very
interested in this issue and we're
working right now with the Qatari
government to try to look at the ethics
in post-conflict situations so that when
Libya needs support they'll get it
that's guitarist goal but working with
them on it so it's a very important um I
think most we agree that I think health
can be construed as a human rights issue
right and furthermore with like these
recent scares would like buy weapons and
such it had this definitely also
security issue and so given how much
poor the UN has with in there is of
human rights insecurity like why housing
the UN taking them like they have so
much legal pool in those areas right so
international legal pool at least so why
is it the UN taking a more active role
in forcing these ihr mandates that we've
been talking about that have such weak
sort of legal force behind them because
there's no structure for the UN to to be
strong there's just there's no way it
can be
and so it has to be done by setting up
standards and norms and forcing people
into a mold it just can't be done but
repeat some of your question again
because I thought is something else
while you were talking well I guess my
point was that global health is so
intricately tied into security and human
rights which are which are things the UN
has great international legal like
Authority is right now but human rights
in many instances turn off the people
you're trying to trying to convince and
human rights is a very politically
charged word and and you know it can
often have the contrary effect to what
you say but it's clear that if there's
an obligation in a world where there are
vaccines and drugs that are being used
in the industrialized countries and
controlling infectious diseases we have
a moral obligation to make access
sustainable throughout the world whether
that's a human right or not I don't know
but it certainly is a moral obligation
so we've given what you just said would
you agree with this whole FAO like seed
bank model thing that that sure that
yeah the unit because the countries
agreed to but isn't that more monetarily
driven rather than like this whole human
rights line well but it's a sustainable
process you know money has to sustain
something that's human right a human
right can be a human right unless you
can provide the you have the money to
provide it what's needed in order to
make that right available to everyone I
think it's
all right well I'd like to thank David
Heyman again thank you any of you have
any questions you can email me happy
answer okay and I'd like to encourage
you all to come next week when we'll
have Vincent grass and yellow so hope to
see you again next week